[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to ET live
today we're going to be talking all
things Bachelorette I'm Kristen Gill
I'm Katie Krause nzn plumbing being here
thanks for having me I feel like we
should dive right into it and then we
got the questions for you as well but
let's start with last night's episode I
want to get into the garret of it all
because he dropped a major bomb shell
who he was previously married yes and
divorce and divorce yeah what do you
make of him
so when we filmed with her we found out
this information and I you know I get
married and they get divorced all the
time I don't think that that is a deal
breaker the story didn't I I feel like
there's some holes in the story in my
opinion you brought up a good point
which was you know that it seemed like
he was placing all the blame on his ex
and I didn't even really like think
about that I just thought that the way
that it was explained I didn't quite
understand why you know things ended and
I guess you know he was young when they
first started dating but yeah I mean I
think in terms of their date they seemed
to have great natural chemistry and it
seems pretty exactly I think I struggle
because them together I do see that
chemistry and I do see her lighting up
and she's so giddy around him and he he
genuinely seems like a good guy but yeah
we've seen what's happened in the media
with his social media accounts and then
when he was describing the divorce and
the reasons for it it was kind of like
yo two people are in that man yeah yeah
yeah his story her story and the truth
like there's something going on there
right like yeah he's only saying outside
he's saying that the family push she
pushed his family away and all this
stuff is like okay well what was she
what ya doing to her like I mean if you
know yeah I agree I think watching the
date last night you could see that
there's a natural chemistry he really
like
sir which is which is nice to see ya it
doesn't seem forced like with some of
the other guys where they're just like
trying so hard to convince everyone that
you know they really care for her and he
it seems natural and and vice versa I
think I still it's a what happened in
the media in the beginning is a hard
pill for me to swallow I he seems like a
nice guy but I just think I don't know
if it was a lapse in you know production
or ABC being able to like really
carefully vet him and other contestants
as we've seen and I just think that you
know it because we all kind of know he
might be a front-runner if he wasn't a
front-runner I think things would have
been handled differently and and how he
was handled in the media so that's kind
of my opinion about that but I don't
know him personally and it's hard
because it's like you know liking
something on Instagram is it necessarily
you know who that person is but it just
shows a lack of concern and maybe a
little bit of ignorance which which is
kind of difficult especially knowing
Becca's kind of political believe do you
want to ask you about one other
contestant Lincoln of course and there's
been he's been charged yeah where the
salts
Warner Brothers released a statement and
said that he lied on the background
check and I'm just curious about your
stance on that and if you think ABC
should have taken more ownership in the
background checks but where do you what
are your thoughts so I don't know I
guess my feelings are mixed because I
know that the background checks are very
thorough yeah yeah I've been through it
I just
I guess I guess the question is if
someone was arrested for something but
not charged
should that be enough to you know not
bring to not bring them on the show
right which I would say maybe you know
because especially if the case is
pending you know I'm sure that that's
something that they could have seen like
figured out it case was closed or if the
case is pending or you know what the
status of it was I think obviously you
know I get why they're not taking
response thank obviously they've known
then they wouldn't have them on the show
but it still it shows I think that
coupled with like the Garrett thing
shows kind of maybe a little bit of
missing piece in vetting some of the
contestants knowing Beca maybe your
three top guys for her okay um Jason
late I'm so team like yes and I'd say
Garrett just because I know yeah and you
can I mean the chemistry is very
palpable
you